this is all the reasons that they keep
my stuff sara is looking at herself as
the conservative see her she asked them
for all the data they held on her
something they're legally obliged to
supply it's fundamentally the digital
equivalent of finding out what people
are saying about you what it estimated
that I was thirty-one male and a
multicultural family none of which I am
the source of this assessment is credit
reference agency Experian he's made up
of things like my transactions my phone
contract my credit score stuff like that
it pulls in masses of data to estimate
people are it's not just the
conservatives who buy this information
Mathew asked labour for his data and
found the same problem with Sarah what
Labour believed me to be was a 65 plus
retired male who earns 55,000 pounds a
year owns his own flat and I don't want
to go too much into my personal life and
but all of that is wrong the parties
combined this data with their own
information to decide who to target
Matthew's data showed labour ranked
every voter in each constituency on key
issues like inequality on austerity in a
similar way to the Liberal Democrats who
we revealed last month with scoring
voters out of a hundred although without
data from Experian the system's broken
and we're at the center of one of the
most defining elections for generations
and our parties are sitting on data sets
from commercial providers that they
believe are dead set and accurate it's
not just the parties that are suffering
from the messaging but democracy will
suffer as a result all the parties told
us they complied with all data
protection law use several sources of
data and we're aware that some weren't
perfect even so they're increasing its
use political parties have gathered data
on voters for years what's changed it's
what they do with it I've got hold of
leach labour party manuals showing how
they use Experian data to target
Facebook ads and I'm told the toys do
something similar so when you see a
political
Facebook and you wonder why it's been
shown to you Experian data is very often
the reason why Experian told us it's
tools show the likely shared
characteristics of groups of people and
so in some cases may not entirely
reflect one individual but when
campaigning is digital data is central
to democracy perhaps especially if it's
wrong rod amantha Sky News